imagine the you are a pig farmer you
live in a small farm in the Philippines
your animals are your family's sole
source of income as long as they're
healthy you know that any day one of
your pigs can catch the flu the swine
flu living in tight quarters one pig
coughing and sneezing may soon lead to
the next big coughing and sneezing until
an outbreak of swine flu has taken over
your farm if it's a bad enough virus the
health of your herd may be gone in the
blink of an eye if you called in a
veterinarian he or she would visit your
farm and take samples from your picks
noses and mouths but then they would
have to drive back into the city to test
those samples in their central lab two
weeks later you'd hear back the results
two weeks maybe just enough time for
infection to spread and take away your
way of life but it doesn't have to be
that way today farmers can take those
samples themselves they can jump right
into the pen and swap their pigs noses
and mouths with a little filter paper
and place a little filter paper in a
tiny tube mix it with some chemicals
that will extract genetic material from
their pigs noses and mouths and without
leaving their farms take a drop of that
genetic material and put it into a
little analyzer smaller than a shoebox
and program it to detect DNA or RNA from
the swine flu virus and within one hour
get back the results visualize the
results this reality is possible because
today we're living in the era of
personal DNA technology every one of us
can actually test DNA ourselves DNA is
the fundamental molecule that carries
genetic instructions that help build the
living world humans have DNA pigs have
DNA even bacteria and some viruses have
DNA too
the genetic instructions encoded in DNA
inform how our bodies develop
function and in many cases that same
information can trigger disease your
genetic information is strung into a
long and twisted molecule the DNA double
helix that has over three billion
letters beginning to end but the lines
that carry meaningful information are
usually very short a few dozen to
several thousand letters long so when
we're looking to answer a question based
on DNA we actually don't need to read
all those 3 billion letters typically
that would be like getting hungry at
night and having to flip through the
whole phone book from cover to cover
pausing at every line just to find the
nearest pizza joint
luckily three decades ago humans started
to invent tools that can find any
specific line of genetic information
these DNA machines are wonderful they
can find any line in DNA the ones they
find it that DNA is still tiny and
surrounded by so much other DNA what
that what these machines then do is copy
the target gene and one copy piles on
top of another millions and millions and
millions of copies until that gene
stands out against the rest and we can
until we can visualize it interpret it
read it understand it until we can
answer does my Pig have the flu or other
questions buried in our own DNA am I at
risk of cancer am i of Irish descent is
that child my son
this ability to make copies of DNA as
simple as it sounds
has transformed our world scientists use
it every day to detect and address
disease to create innovative medicines
to modify foods to assess whether or
food is safe to eat or whether it's
contaminated with deadly bacteria even
judges use the output of these machines
in court to decide whether someone is
innocent or guilty based on DNA evidence
and the inventor of the DNA coping
technique was awarded the Nobel Prize in
Chemistry in 1993 but for 30 years the
power of genetic analysis has been
confined to the ivory tower or bigwig
PhD scientists work well several
companies around the world are working
on making this same technology
accessible to everyday people like the
pig farmer like you I co-founded one of
these companies three years ago together
with a fellow biologist and friend of
mine Zeek Alvarez Saavedra we decided to
make personal DNA machines that anyone
could use our goal was to bring DNA
science to more people in new places and
we started working in our basements we
had a simple question what could the
world look like if everyone could
analyze DNA we were curious as curious
as you would have been if I had shown
you this picture in 1980 you would have
thought wow I can now call my uncle Enda
from the car and wish her a happy
birthday
I can call anyone anytime this is the
future little did you know you would tap
on that phone to make dinner
reservations for you and I'm Glenda to
celebrate together with another tab
you'd be ordering her gift and yet one
more tab and you'd be liking auntie
Glenda on Facebook and all of this while
sitting on the toilet
it is it is notoriously hard to predict
where new technology might take us and
the same is true for personal DNA
technology today for example I could
never have imagined that a truffle
farmer of all people would use personal
DNA machines dr. Paul Thomas grows
truffles for a living and we see him
pictured here holding the first UK
cultivated truffle in his hands on one
of his farms truffles are this delicacy
that stems from a fungus growing on the
roots of living trees and it's a rare
fungus some species may fetch 3000 seven
thousand or more dollars per kilogram
I've learned from Paul that the stakes
for a truffle farmer can be really high
when he sources new truffles to grow on
his farms he's exposed to the threat of
knock-offs
truffles they look and feel like the
real thing but they're of lower quality
but even to a trained eye like Paul's
even when looked under a microscope
these truffles can pass for authentic so
in order to grow the highest quality
truffles the ones that chefs all over
the world will fight over Paul has to
use DNA analysis
isn't that mind-blowing I bet you will
never look at that black truffle risotto
again without thinking of its genes but
personal DNA machines can also save
human lives professor yi and Goodfellow
is a virologist at the at the University
of Cambridge and last year he traveled
to Sierra Leone when the Ebola outbreak
broke out in western Africa he quickly
realized the doctors there lacked the
basic tools to detect and combat disease
results could take up to a week to come
back and that's way too long for the
patients and the families who are
suffering Ian's decided to move his lab
into McKenney Sierra Leone
here we see Ian Goodfellow moving over
ten tons of equipment into a pop-up tent
that he would equipped to detect and
diagnose the virus and sequence it
within 24 hours
right here's a surprise the same
equipment that you could use at its lab
in the UK to sequence and diagnose Ebola
just wouldn't work under these
conditions we're talking 35 Celsius heat
and over 90% humidity here but instead
Ian could use personal DNA machines
small enough to be placed in front of
the air conditioning unit to keep
sequencing the virus and keep saving
lives this may seem like an extreme
place for DNA analysis but let's move on
to an even more extreme environment
outer space let's talk about DNA
analysis in space when astronauts live
aboard the International Space Station
they're orbiting the planet 250 miles
high they're traveling at 17,000 miles
per hour picture that you're seeing 15
sunsets and sunrises every day you're
also living in microgravity floating and
under these conditions our bodies can do
funky things one of these things is that
our immune systems get suppressed making
astronauts more prone to infection a 16
year old girl a high school student from
New York annasophia bugger eyath
wondered whether changes to the DNA of
Austrians could be related to this
immune suppression and through a science
competition called genes in space on a
Sofia design an experiment to test this
hypothesis using a personal DNA machine
aboard the International Space Station
here we see Anna Sophia on April 8 2016
in Cape Canaveral watching her
experiment launch to the International
Space Station that cloud of smoke is the
rocket that brought Anna Sophia's
experiment to the International Space
Station were three days later astronaut
tim peake
carried out her experiment in
microgravity personal DNA machines are
now aboard the International Space
Station where they can help monitor
living conditions and protect the lives
of astronauts a 16 year old designing a
DNA experiment to protect the lives of
ostrich may seem like a rarity
the mark of a child genius well to me
they signal something bigger that DNA
technology is finally within the reach
of every one of you a few years ago a
college student armed with a personal
computer could code an app an app that
is now a social network with more than 1
billion users could we be moving into a
world of one personal DNA machine in
every home
I know families who are already living
in this reality the Daniel's family for
example set up a DNA lab in the basement
of their suburban Chicago home this is
not a family made of PhD scientists this
is a family like any other they just
like to spend time together doing fun
creative things by day brian is an
executive at a private equity firm at
nights and on weekends he experiments
with DNA alongside his kids ages 7 and 9
as a way to explore the living world
last time I called them they were
checking out homegrown produce from the
backyard garden they were testing
tomatoes that they had picked taking a
flesh of their skin putting it in a test
tube mixing it with chemicals to extract
DNA and then using their home copier
their home DNA copier to test those
tomatoes for genetically engineered
traits for the Daniel's family the
personal DNA machine is like the
chemistry set for the 21st century most
of us may not yet be diagnosing genetic
conditions in our kitchen sinks or doing
at-home paternity testing but we've
definitely reached a point in history
where every one of you could actually
get hands-on with DNA in your kitchen
you could copy paste and analyze DNA and
extract meaningful information from it
and it's at times like this that
profound transformation is bound to
happen moments one a transformative
powerful technology that was before
limited to a select few in the ivory
tower finally becomes within the reach
of every one of us from farmers to
schoolchildren think about the moon
one phone stopped being plugged into the
wall by cords or when computers left the
mainframe and entered your home or your
office the ripples of the personal DNA
revolution may be hard to predict but
one thing is certain revolutions don't
go backwards and DNA technology is
already spreading faster than our
imagination so if you're curious get up
close and personal with DNA today it is
in our DNA to be curious thank you